Vin Diesel has a trilogy of sci-fi action
movies sitting in the top 10 on Netflix — one
of which was made over 20 years ago!
But as "Riddickulous" as it may sound, there's
a simple reason for the franchise's uptick
in popularity.
Despite being involved in some of the biggest
franchises of the 21st century, Vin Diesel
has rarely seen eye-to-eye with critics.
While the actor drew some acclaim for early
roles in films like The Iron Giant and Saving
Private Ryan, subsequent efforts such as A
Man Apart, The Pacifier, and Knockaround Guys
were largely dismissed as empty action vehicles.
Still, that hasn't slowed Diesel down one
bit, as the actor has been working steadily
on dozens of projects over the last 25 years.
Furthermore, die-hard fans of Diesel's work
in a long-dormant science fiction franchise
have seen a loose-fitting trilogy of the actor's
films returning to the limelight.
As strange as it is, Richard B. Riddick has
emerged from the darkness and is currently
overshadowing much of the competition on Netflix.
Currently, all three films in David Twohy's
dark futuristic science fiction thriller series
are sitting pretty in Netflix's top 10 list
of movies — a fact that probably has a lot
to do with ongoing rumors that Diesel will
be returning to the franchise to reunite with
Twohy yet again.
The Riddick franchise launched back in 2000
with its first entry, Pitch Black.
The film saw a group of survivors attempting
to navigate a mysterious alien world filled
with deadly nocturnal creatures after their
ship crash lands.
Ironically, prisoner and serial killer Richard
B. Riddick, who possesses the unique ability
to see in the dark, becomes the only person
who might be able to lead the group to safety,
causing the survivors to reluctantly release
him.
"I am worth twice as much alive."
Since the character took off in popularity
following Pitch Black, many spinoff projects
were put into the works.
A sequel came in the form of The Chronicles
of Riddick, while an animated short film,
The Chronicles of Riddick: Dark Fury, filled
in the story between the two movies.
Elsewhere, two well-received video games filled
in other parts of the character's mysterious backstory.
The Chronicles of Riddick: Escape From Butcher
Bay showed how Riddick broke out of prison
prior to being caught by a bounty hunter and
placed on the ship from Pitch Black.
Meanwhile, The Chronicles of Riddick: Assault
on Dark Athena sees the character trying to
battle his way out of a mercenary ship.
Finally, there was Riddick in 2013.
The film took the character back to basics
by having him fight for his life on a hostile
planet full of deadly alien creatures.
Of the three main movies, this one is currently
the highest in the Netflix top 10, with Chronicles
of Riddick and Pitch Black showing up in descending
order.
A fourth mainline "Riddick" movie was confirmed
recently, with both writer-director David
Twohy and franchise star Vin Diesel set to
return.
Titled Riddick 4: Furya, the film will purportedly
see the character, who is the last surviving
member of an alien race called the Furyans,
return to his home planet.
According to Twohy, the film will reveal that
Riddick is actually not the last of the Furyans.
Twohy has also said that the survivors are
very much alike to Diesel's character, a factor
that will probably either see him team up
with them against external forces or set up
a Furyan battle royale between many of the
gruff-voiced human hybrids.
While more concrete details like returning
cast members or a release date are still incoming,
the cult following of the franchise will no
doubt be spreading the word that the property
is returning — hence the sudden uptick in
interest in the series on Netflix.
Whether this one can finally impress critics,
however, remains to be seen.